[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice merry christmas america we're so
glad you're with us thank you for
joining us open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
breaking news uh president biden has
given americans a gift today
at least a bunch of you he has extended
the student loan
non-repayment
uh for another 90 days and so may 1st
you will have to start paying your
student loans back it was prior to that
90 days was going to be what february
1st or something like that you were
going to have to start
and so
some of you are saying woohoo now i
don't have to pay my student loans till
may i can kick the can further down the
road
our advice to you of course is to pay
them off as soon as possible regardless
of when the president says
the
payments are due
you use this time off this interest time
off as a way to accelerate your
repayment rather than a way to put off
your repayment beware of politicians
coming bearing gifts
uh ronald reagan used to say that some
of the scariest words in the english
language are
i'm from the government and i'm here to
help
yeah
so uh just just keep that in mind but
yeah it's a it's good news though i mean
it's going to help some of you have had
a tough couple of years and it gives you
a chance to continue to do this but
please don't use it as a way to
put off doing what you know you've got
to do and that student loan is not going
away it's the monster in the closet and
you need to get it paid off the highest
and best use of money the reason to
become a baby steps millionaire an
everyday millionaire the reason to save
and invest is something more than just
the piling up of stuff
we all know that it is better to give
than to receive
um some know that more than others
but changing your family tree and
outrageous generosity are the highest
and best callings of wealth
by the way those are the most fun things
you'll ever do with wealth
get you some stuff get you a nice car
i got a shiny truck down in the parking
lot
that i like that's fine but if your
definition of happiness is what you
drive you're shallow
so yeah let's let's draw back a little
bit look up a little bit raise our chins
a little bit and set a higher calling on
this whole money thing and we talk about
you know there's about five things you
have to do with money if you want to be
successful with money one of them is to
become and establish a pattern of
generosity in your life
and so what we do every year because we
are pretty much cornballs around here on
the ramsay show we are corny and proud
of it
um
is we do all kinds of stuff like we ask
what you're thankful for thanksgiving
that's corny and we're proud of it just
like it's a walking dead joke right but
that's okay i'm 61 i'm a grandpa i can
do this crap by the way i own the thing
so i can do this crap so there you go
uh so this is what we're doing we're
going to talk about generosity this hour
and next hour next hour we always do a
giving show
as our last live show
of the year you'll get best ofs until
january the 3rd so i just go ahead and
be ready and by the way best doves are
actually
our best which means it's better than
sometimes when we're here so you can go
ahead and listen but uh you'll be
getting those those kinds of shows but
today for three hours we're going to
take your calls those of you that have a
giving story
because we want to set the bar on
generosity we want to inspire
call people to
generosity
pay the person's groceries in front of
you in line the person in front of you
at the coffee thing in line and by the
by that per person behind you whatever
you know go ahead and just do some weird
stuff with money leave a a thousand
dollar tip at a table buy somebody a car
do something wicked weird awesome with
money that just blows people's minds and
by the way your mind will be blown in
the process and that's the beauty of
generosity is everybody
benefits including the giver
so i want to hear your giving stories
those of you have done something really
cool with giving and i know you're
modest and i know you're humble and you
don't want to tell your story but you
didn't give it anyway god gave it he
just used you to do it so shut up i want
to hear your story so you call and make
us cry that's what your job is and maybe
you received
something
and maybe you'll give somebody an idea
because you received a gift that was
unbelievable now i don't want to hear
stories about 20 tips i mean that you
should be doing this stuff anyway
but
if the pizza guy says how you do you say
how you're doing and the pizza guy says
uh better than i deserve that's cute
q4
that's code for he listens to the ramsay
show she listens to the ramsay show
they're working this extra job to get
out of debt you have to triple your tip
to them if they say that that's just
code that's not generosity you're just
you're just doing some stuff but i'm
talking about something big i want to
hear some stories right now the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five
two two five you're giving or receiving
stories we're inspiring generosity today
howard is in new york hey howard what's
up merry christmas
yes merry christmas dave
so
the short story is my wife and i
blessed the city mission of schenectady
with our first six-figure gift
whoa over a hundred grand
yeah and it felt amazing
wow just
we've been long time donors small donors
to the city mission
i had a side note backstory
been a
board president of the local animal
protective foundation
very well aware of non-profits in the
schenectady and paid close attention to
the city mission over the years donated
along the way
but they the city mission does amazing
work they're providing shelter for
nearly 100 men women and children
they serve more than 600 meals daily
along with
one thing that i found very important
they do this while providing everyone
dignity and provide training and life
skills
to graduate yeah
and and move on graduate from the street
yeah
that's good work that is good work very
cool so you also
you're saying this is a good investment
not only because of the work they do but
they're efficient in their work it's not
a waste of money it's not like giving it
to the government and a
penny on the dollar ends up going to the
actual thing
exactly they're highly efficient and in
fact many of
the people that they bring in off the
streets and train they train to actually
do the work of the mission including
building the buildings in our case it
was
doing work on a brand new courtyard
and this courtyard is in the center of
all of their buildings including uh
transitional apartments
and um places for family life center
et cetera very cool it's an amazing
facility actually very cool very cool
and you said that's your first time to
give a six-figure gift so you've had a
pattern of generosity but you're ramping
it up
exactly yeah very cool what's your net
worth
um
roughly four million good
cool good yeah six figure gifts ought to
be a way of life now you're awesome man
you're awesome i'm so proud of you and
you gotta know people you gotta know
listen tell them howard it feels so
stinking good
it feels amazing and in fact um
my wife made the point that said that
she told us
that
this may have been the best gift to her
she's ever quote received amen
it's almost selfish it feels so good i
love it well done brother touchdown man
there we go that's what i'm talking
about that's what i'm talking about it's
a giving show right here on the ramsay
show
[Music]
is
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget don't
worry it's worth it
[Music]
you know a lot of folks are
afraid these days
they're afraid of inflation they're
afraid of coveted
i'm afraid they're gonna die
[Music]
they're afraid about their jobs
and it's causing a whole new surge in
get rich quick stuff out there
people trying to
cut corners and
build a house of cards and you know what
happens to a house of cards everybody's
you know they fall in right when you
build a jenga tower it falls
well i got great news if you really want
to build wealth we have a huge event on
thursday january 13th called building
wealth
and we're going to talk to you about
proven
tactics
not fly by night
not you've got to spend three thousand
dollars in a weekend to learn how to buy
nothing down real estate which doesn't
work by the way
but we're going to teach you how to
really build wealth rachel cruz george
campbell and i we're going to make sense
of the get-rich-quick noise
and really talk about how wealth
really is built why to build it and
where it comes from we've already sold
out of the in-person tickets about 1500
of those sold out for the event in about
three or four days
so we're offering the live stream
completely free
you do not want to miss this event go to
ramseysolutions.com wealth to register
for the free live stream of the building
wealth live event on january the 13th
thank you for joining us it's our annual
giving show where we talk about giving
and receiving we talk about generosity
and uh we're hearing your stories if you
have a great generosity story uh
receiving or giving i need to hear from
you the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five susan
is in pittsburgh
hi susan merry christmas
hi dave merry christmas to you very cool
what's up tell me your giving story
okay so
my story is about being on the receiving
end of a gift
i was in college my last semester of
nursing school and
i had paid for school at this point with
loans
and
my last semester i came down to owing
about six thousand dollars to finish off
and graduate
and
everybody in my family had tried to
co-sign for me and i kept being denied
for the loan
i was pretty desperate because it was
very hard for me at this point to even
just make it through college and be
where i was and so i asked a friend of
mine um
if she would be willing to try and
co-sign a loan for me
and
she told me that she always
ran all of her financial decisions by
her parents and that um
she would have to talk to them and get
back to me and
i soon got a call from
her mom
and
she stated you know that
well first she asked me you know what
situation i was in and sort of the
details surrounding like my schooling
and how things were going and um
she then told me that they wouldn't be
advising their daughter to co-sign a
loan for me
but that that they wanted to gift me the
six thousand dollars to finish paying
for my nursing school
yeah
i noticed something stupid but yes to a
nice gift i love it yes exactly
um of course i was crying i was beside
myself
i
just felt like it was so generous of
them to to do that for me um you know
just being a friend of their daughters
um and since then my husband and i have
been on our debt-free journey and we're
now debt-free
um
and we're we're really looking forward
to being as generous as they were to me
someday man that is very
cool
yeah and and i i actually had a friend
of mine years ago i gosh it was probably
30 years ago he was telling me the story
that a guy that he didn't even know that
was a wealthy guy in that community
heard about him and his studies
and uh paid for his entire college
just because he heard the same kind of
thing it was like a
like one degree of separation like with
you and that lady and through your
friend and uh that's pretty incredible
so yeah that's a cool thing pick up a
pick up a tuition bill from somebody
that's uh worthy and you were obviously
worthy you were you were somebody who
almost there
you you had paid a price you were you
were scratching and clawing trying to
finish it up and get out of there and
you know you weren't goofing off you
weren't you weren't some trust fund baby
you know you you were right and that you
you were just attractive to them and
that's very cool
yeah
i feel very blessed that that happened
and that you know that i'm at where i'm
at today yeah and i i i bet you that's
probably going to cost you at least 60
or 80 thousand dollars that you're
probably gonna have to do that about 10
or 12 times
you're not wrong you're not wrong
that's a good way to pay it forward i
like it
you're amazing it's good to talk to you
susan that's a great story a great
giving
story so thank you very very cool yeah
higher ed is a
that's not a bad plan at all this is our
generosity show that we do once a year
where we talk generosity receiving and
giving if you've got a story the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five stephen is in decatur
alabama hey steven merry christmas
merry christmas dave can you hear me
okay absolutely tell me your giving
story
yes sir my family uh got hooked up with
a single mom of four children they came
into the school year pretty late and we
got to know her and became friends with
her
and
she's been scratching and clawing and
running for like two years her family
history is
very deep into
drugs and what have you she decided to
change her life around a year and a half
ago
earlier this year her house burned down
so she lost all of her possessions saved
for what was in the backyard in a
storage shed oh my god and she and she's
just been scratching and clawing and
trying to get as much assistance as she
can
and my wife and i we looked at each
other as like okay is there any way that
we can help this lady out
she moved into the same rv park as us
and what she moved in was pretty much a
dump
it wasn't very well the floor was
falling through the roof was leaking and
she actually found
a
newer rv uh like a late 90s rv that was
in like a grandma
yeah grandma and pop
type rv just really well cared for you
know it's just an older model
and it was at a very good price of like
2 300 and my wife and i at first told
her hey we'll sponsor you and go dollar
for dollar
but at the end of the time where they
say hey we got to get this thing offer a
lot my wife and i just decided to
purchase it and gift it to her for
christmas
and also she was struggling with
employment and the place that i haul for
is hiring like crazy so i was able to
get her a job interview there to double
her income
to try to take care of those babies wow
that's cool that's a lot of bang for
your buck i mean you give somebody a
place to live for 2 300 bucks
oh yes that's strong
yep and
just like teaching how to fish plenty
are in the right direction to double
their income just by changing jobs and
i'm sure she'll float yeah she's going
to do just fine she's going to oh yeah
just fine she's got people like you
looking over her shoulder man well done
that's fun isn't it
oh yes it is
yeah
so how long did you and your wife talk
about it before you decided to just
write the check
um we're in
we're in baby step three right now and
we had the 2300 extra and it's like well
i mean
we don't plan on really doing anything
with it so why don't we just help this
family out and took us about two seconds
to to decide our generosity
well you know you will never struggle
with money as long as you have that
open-handed
mentality
oh yes so well done sir i'm proud of you
man that's awesome thanks for sharing
your story very good you know the thing
about holding your money with an open
hand some of it might blow out
some of that money because it's just
kind of laying there it might leave
but also the fact that your hand is open
more money can come into your hand when
you hold it with a tight fist no more
can come in
what you have won't get away but you
can't add any because your fist is
already wrapped up
and so there's a beautiful picture when
you say open-handed
even a dog understands a clenched fist
or an open hand
you got a dog bothering you just open
your hand and squat down
come here baby they'll calm right down
look at you unless they're crazy you
know
even a dog understands that you double
up your fist anywhere in the world they
understand what you mean though
closed spirit
open
spirit
generosity
generous people are
highly attractive
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
this is our annual generosity show where
we talk about giving and we talk about
receiving
at ramsey solutions we now have 1058
people as of this week on our team
a couple of buildings full of people
doing incredible work uh doing an
incredible job
uh one of the things we do here and i
stole this from somebody a few years ago
so i'm gonna offer it to you guys
especially those of you that own or run
businesses and i hope you'll steal the
idea in addition to our normal paid time
off our normal pto your vacation time or
whatever after you've been here a year
we will give you an additional week off
per year
to serve in a ministry
somewhere so you can go on the mission
field you can go
serve soup at the mission
you can uh
one guy the other day one of our
technology guys went and built a website
for this mat a massive website for this
ministry took a whole week
and just plugged in for this non-profit
this ministry and just did a great great
job so we're always trying to
integrate this whole idea of generosity
into our team as well and we our team
has all kinds of opportunities
throughout the year to participate in
all kinds of different generosity
initiatives and consequently guess what
we end up hiring a whole bunch of
generous people and the people that are
here become
increasingly generous so part of our
giving show is to have some of our team
on
and miss emily cummings is with us
emily's been with us seven and a half
years she's a real estate coach over in
ramsey trusted working with real estate
agents around the nation that that are
ramsey trusted and emily's been doing a
great job for a long time almost a
decade now
so uh but you got a great giving story
out here tell me what it is yeah so i
really want to rewind a couple of years
about two years ago
my husband and i had started saving to
buy a house
we had put away a good chunk of money um
and then at that time my husband wanted
to go back to school and so we ended up
sacrificing that money felt like that
that was the better decision to
to put that money towards his income
that we would be losing yeah that's a
hard call
yeah
you know his education increase versus
buying a house sure that's a tough call
good but we're really thankful obviously
we had our emergency fund in place we
were debt-free at that time so it was a
pretty easy decision to make but that
meant that we were sacrificing
the the house purchase that was going to
take significantly longer
based off of our
kind of estimations we weren't even
going to be able to save up the money
until two years after he even got hired
so we had been um he'd been in school
for about six months and i had coffee
with my dad
and we were just talking and he's like
well i want to talk to you about
something i was like okay he says i've
been praying about this for an entire
year
but i want to give you a hundred
thousand dollars to buy a house dang
exactly i
i was like what
um and my dad has always been a very
generous person um has helped me out
when we were struggling to get pregnant
uh financially gave us money even then
um but that was completely unexpected um
and so and even then when he when he
said the words and i'm going to give you
this money you know it's like the dream
you have that you won the lottery like
this isn't real like this is not going
to happen so you didn't like spill your
coffee then
no
almost spit it out at him but i'm
yeah oh my gosh
um and so we
he ended up uh gifting us the money and
were able to of course use one of the
ramsey trusted eops uh kyle and casey
wallace to them
uh to buy a house even in this market
and um just
we've been in our house three months now
and just completely blown away just now
i mean this is thanksgiving yeah yeah so
we we closed um
and moved in in september so this is
real literally three months two days ago
so
freaking christmas oh my gosh yeah
yeah so i'm i mean my parents so your
dad and mom have obviously done very
well financially yes and this didn't put
a strain on them at all no um and so
he's thinking i'd rather see him enjoy
it while i'm here
he yes that was exactly and he saw you
all behaving
he's not gonna he's not gonna bless that
if you're
out there spending like you're in
congress right well i it's funny i um i
facilitated financial peace class at my
church they go to church this and they
took the class so i got to teach them
uh because they they my dad was always
been frugal but he never budgeted before
until he took the class and so
it's kind of cool to see that come full
circle we had already gotten out of debt
ourselves
and then my parents took the class and
now here we are where they're generously
giving
to us so that is so cool
i love it now how old are you and your
husband so i'm 38 and my husband is 35.
cool cool and you're able to buy a very
nice home with a hundred thousand
dollars down yes yes gift not not loan
right yeah yeah way to go that's so cool
way to go dad touchdown
yeah a nice cup of coffee yeah
i like it very very nice well and and
the other thing that does is it it sets
his
it burns his legacy into your dna
you you can't
you can't avoid generosity now
it's it's now become a part of who you
are you you can't you don't have an
option it's just it reset your brain and
where it's it's an automatic default
mechanism for you to be generous and he
just re you were already that way but he
just you know he he just dumped a tote
a ton of chemicals into your brain that
caused you to permanently be generous
now that's very neat yeah and we're just
thankful to be on the four five and six
baby steps now we're like okay
how quickly can we pay off our mortgage
so that we can start doing something
very similar and who can we impact
because of that amen that's what i mean
you know so yeah the pay it forward you
can't keep it from happening i love it
great story emily very cool thanks for
sharing that absolutely merry christmas
give your dad a hug for me tell him i
said he's awesome okay i like that
very cool stuff
very cool hey i got to tell you man
that's that's amazing i got a friend of
mine that um decided he was his kids
were he was the last he was the last
person in his
uh uh
family tree to be in debt and so uh he
paid cash for all his kids houses
not bad
under the condition that they would sign
an agreement to never borrow money of
any kind ever
and that they would teach the grandkids
to never borrow money any kind ever so
that it's not wasted in other words
you're not gonna pay up by buy you a
house then you go refinance it by boat
right so uh that'll piss you off right
so you don't want to do that but yeah
you just he laid it out and all three of
his kids are you know 30 years old
millionaires now
because they hand out a house payment
all through their 20s
and they make good careers and they just
started paying they started investing
and um i mean that serious jump start
right there
pretty pretty impressive i like that
yeah we did have a debt-free scream one
time the guy
couple was on with their two grown kids
and they did a debt-free scream they
were they were baby steps millionaires
and um they had they were doing the debt
free scream because they had paid off
their house
and then at the end of the right before
they did their debt-free scream they
said oh and by the way
we just wrote checks our kid two kids
step one standing on each side don't
know this but we just wrote checks and
paid off both of their houses too so all
three families are now doing a debt free
scream together the kids are crying mom
and dad are crying i'm crying it was
great it was amazing so generosity is
cool guys all right let's go to greg in
fort wayne indiana hi greg welcome to
the ramsay show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey we've got a receiving story back in
2015
we got a call from our uncle and he said
he wanted to contribute to the kids
college fund and we you know we talked
about it we said hey that would be
awesome thanks so much
and up until that point we'd only saved
about 3 500 to our college fund for the
kids
and they were already 14 and 12. so we
weren't doing very good for them
so anyway a couple weeks later i get
home from work and my wife's sitting on
the couch and she's crying
and i was like hey babe what's going on
and she's like hey we just got the
checks from uncle john you need to take
a look at these so i did i pulled them
out and i noticed that each one of the
kids got 1400
and we were we were so excited about
that
and she looks at me and she's like hey
you need to look at those checks again
and so i did so and i noticed that i
left off a zero each one of the kids got
20 or 14 thousand dollars towards their
college fund
and so you know we were just blown away
by that good man
yeah and the only thing cooler than that
dave is
over the next three years he also did it
again for each one of them whoa
so he gave over a hundred thousand
dollars yeah he did 112 000 over a
course of four years and we were just
absolutely blown away by that that's the
rich uncle we've all been looking for
i love it
very cool that's a great story oh man
that's fun
the annual giving show right here on the
ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show
we always talk about generosity around
here but we also take the last live show
of the year which is today
and gave you three hours of generosity
we want your giving stories we're
talking about the power of generosity
what generosity does
how it inspires us to be better people
how things move
around life is good life is
good
and so we want to hear from you if
you've got a good generosity story maybe
you're the giver maybe you're the
receiver but inspire others you maybe
maybe you'll give them an idea by what
happened to you or what you were able to
do
and uh it changes changes everything
this thing called generosity i'm
convinced if we the people
increased our generosity about three
percent a year
every single one of us
that we can put the government out of
business
there's a lot of good in that sentence
just think about it
hey i'm i'm serious if we just start
taking care of each other the way we're
supposed to
you can make them irrelevant they're
already irrelevant but you would just
kind of put a highlighter on it
be pretty incredible julie's with us in
chicago hi julie welcome to the ramsay
show tell me your giving story
hi dave i'm so glad to be able to share
this story with you it's actually a
story of receiving and giving eight
years ago december 2013 my husband
steve's cancer was starting to spin out
of control
and that month he was part of a clinical
trial and it caused problems so we
actually had to exit the trial
then we started radiation treatments
at the same time the national mural
registry he was registered on the
national marrow registry and we were
looking for a stem cell match
for
what was to be a stem cell transplant
his third one that would be coming
around the corner and we were at the
hospital every day
um
meanwhile our kids were
10 14 and 16
and we were just trudging through life
every single day
them going to school and we were going
to the hospital every day
we also applied for disability for him
and we were looking at
a few months of no income while we were
waiting for a disability to kick in we
were down to about um
a three-month emergency fund
he was now at this point unable to help
me make decisions about money and you
know all of these huge decisions that
were looming
um and we had a very uncertain future at
that point so i just did not know what
to do about paying bills and let alone
you know helping my kids have a nice
christmas in the middle of all this
so i was fully relying on god to take
care of our needs
and then as more people became aware of
our situation
that's when generosity just started
pouring in
there were a number of things we
experienced um but especially there's
one sweet way that a group of 12 friends
showed love and care to our kids
especially
they called it the 12 days of christmas
and every day after school the kids
would come home and find a basket on the
porch
for 12 days leading up to the holiday
and every day they you know if they
themed it as best they could to the song
the 12 days of christmas but the kids
got baskets full of toys candy
sports equipment movies games books
yummy food
yeah it was really great and my husband
also got you know gifts in there as well
because he needed the you know support
and encouragement himself and it was a
bright spot in our otherwise sad and
very stressful december
we also got
cards
from people that some of them we didn't
know very well at all
um that just sent us checks and cash and
just a number of ways that god worked
everything out for us and then i was
able to piece together everything until
he died three months after christmas
um
my kids were able to experience i mean
they told me separately you know over
that time frame and then later on
reflecting back that they just saw how
god took care of them and our whole
family through the generosity of other
people
and um it really stirred me to be more
generous especially at christmas time
going through a hard time in life is
just it's always hard but it can feel
extra hard when you're going through
something like this at christmas
so three years after my husband died um
there was another family
in our congregation that was going
through
almost identical things
and um i was a member of choir at church
and i went to my friends at choir and
said hey somebody did you know a group
of friends did this for us
a few years ago can we do this for this
other family
and it was really special to pass along
that blessing to another family at the
holiday
amen
good that's good yeah and you'll keep
that alive
um yeah that's um
man that's poignant wow
powerful
so cool so very cool
oh man
but yeah it's um
you know it doesn't take
like uh
a million dollars
it just takes noticing and
action it takes more time than it does
money
to be creative in your generosity i mean
those people bringing gifts over every
day for 12 days that that's you know
that's a thing right
yeah it's tangible it's a way of putting
your arm around somebody in a way and
you know i'm there with you i'm there
for you
so hey you know i want to tell you one
other thing right before my husband
about a year before he
died um he was in a remission but it
wasn't going very well but our church
did financial peace university
and uh so
most of the congregation went through it
and so we did
and my husband had always taken care of
the money and paid the bills and you
know with not a lot of input from me
and we were able to you know
talk about money
get our you know head screwed on tight
and talking together about this and have
a plan
and it wasn't very long after that it
all got you know
my became my responsibility
and i knew exactly what to do i knew
exactly what to do and i knew exactly
what to do after he passed away
thank you very much wow thank you that's
that's powerful and
you know too many times one of the
spouses handles all the money and that
seems to be okay until they're gone
and if they're gone suddenly
uh and you don't know where you know you
can't even find the bill drawer you
don't even know where their checkbook is
much less where stuff stored or what
where the bank lock i mean people don't
know
uh the amount of mysteries that are
going on around that time is just
uh
and the more sudden someone passes
oftentimes the worse that is so it's a
good word from you to say get tooled up
uh because you never know because y'all
weren't that old how old was he when he
passed
uh he was 56 i was 45. yeah yeah you
weren't you weren't you weren't old
people you know
no unless you're 18. in which case
everybody's old but yeah
share your passwords there were a few
passwords that died with him that i was
unable to get into a few different yeah
yeah remember flickr he had all of his
pictures
loaded up onto flickr and uh you know
never gonna access that yeah
it is what it is sometimes as they say
yeah
yeah yeah you need a password uh storage
system for sure or both yeah shared
between spouses but i picture
i i like to picture that he's up there
and every now and then he can just
roll back the clouds like a curtain
and just take a peek and just say hey
they're doing okay yeah so sounds like
you're doing okay sounds like you're
doing pretty good
we're doing okay yeah good yeah thank
you hey thanks for sharing that that's
powerful i appreciate you julie very
nice very nice
yeah
there's something
that happens in the human spirit when
you take your eyes off your selfish self
and you reach those eyes over and you
lay them on someone else suddenly you
realize everybody's got a story
everybody's got something going on
maybe you ought to be a little nicer
ever including me
[Laughter]
just made this a reminder to me but yeah
but everybody's got a story you know
that was that person over there that you
thought was just grouchy and
um you know
you know you have no idea what they went
through this morning
so uh yeah get your eyes off yourself
yourself and the season is about that
but generosity is about that
and it really does
i mean i said this earlier to emily when
she was on our team member here but it
really does reform your brain
when you have a dramatic generosity
event
whether you're the giver or the receiver
something that that is that has a weight
to it that you feel it and in her case
in julie's case at 12 days of christmas
that had a weight to it
and it left a mark it leaves a an
impression
and that's what generosity does it
reforms who you are
and that's what you want
we all need a little reforming
this is the ramsay shot
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
merry christmas america we're so glad
you're here open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five there are five things you
must do with money if you want to be
successful
with money
one of those is you have to learn to
become generous
generosity the data all shows us the
among millionaires that we've studied
among people who live successful
well-rounded lives that they are
generous and generosity extends beyond
just giving someone money it's the
spirit around which you do that
generosity is holding the door for
someone when they got their arm load of
groceries
generosity is a smile
generosity is kindness when someone's
hurting
generosity sometimes is not talking
remember that when you're with your
family this week
generous
people
are highly attractive
they have a tendency to prosper
more than selfish people when you walk
in a room and you bump into a taker or
you bump into a giver
your body physically recoils
when you're having a conversation with a
taker
you feel like you need to take a shower
after you met with them
quite the opposite when you meet with a
giver
even if there's no business transacted
even if there's not a an exchange of
goods or services or ideas it's a simple
conversation when you meet with a giver
it's a different experience
even if you meet them the first time or
the hundredth time
it's a different experience
we all know takers and we all know
givers you know the interesting decision
the interesting thing is people
sometimes don't do not correlate this
correctly with prosperity
you don't wait until you're prosperous
to become generous you become generous
and it's one of the key elements that
will cause prosperity to come towards
you
and it's not mystical it's not magical
it's simple you're simply
a better person
and it was a decision you get to make
suddenly like right now
ta-da
now i am a generous person
ten minutes ago i wasn't i can just
decide to be that you can just decide
it's like a lot of character things you
can just decide sometimes it requires an
event for you to decide sometimes you
just look at yourself in the mirror and
go
i think what ramsay's saying is right i
think generosity matters i'm just going
to be generous so we're going to promote
generosity it's what we always do but we
really do it in the last live show of
the year which is today so today is
dedicated all three hours to giving
stories giving and receiving stories to
inspire everyone to be better at giving
and better at receiving more of it and
more wise
with it we're not talking about enabling
we're talking about giving lift to
people and things
that need it
and that are going to heal be more
hopeful
because of your generosity
so let's hear your generosity stories
phone numbers triple eight eight two
five five two two five and i want big
deal stories i want stories that make
you cry
so you call in make us laugh make us cry
make us remember
to be more
generous
triple eight eight two five
two brett is in salt lake city hi brett
welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks so much dave it's truly an
honor to speak to you today appreciate
the call you too sir tell us about your
giving story
so we are actually on the end of a
receiving story and this is a
community-based receiving story
i'll give you just a really brief
background of what's happened my wife
and i went in to the hospital on august
31st for a delivery of our fourth child
um everything was going normally until
her water broke and within minutes she
was struggling to breathe
she passed out and she actually went
into cardiac arrest whoa
from uh yeah she had a rare complication
it's called amniotic fluid embolism
the amniotic fluid mixed in her
bloodstream in a kind of a lethal level
so a rapid response team was called they
started performing cpr on her as well as
life-saving medications and then a
second team of doctors led by an ob on
site
rushed in and did an emergency c-section
to deliver
our baby
in time they were able to get a pulse
back for my wife they were able to get
her stable enough to get on a live
flight and taken to a
higher level of care hospital in salt
lake and then our son was also
life-flighted to that same hospital
to receive nicu care
he was in the hospital for eight days
and my wife cami she was in the hospital
from august 31st
to november 27th dealing with a variety
of different complications
um one secondary thing that happened
from the afe was that she had a massive
stroke
that um
has left the left side of her body
mostly paralyzed that's something that
she's dealing with now
so that's kind of the background of what
we had going on and the community
outreach has just been
unbelievable
we had a good friend and neighbor she
set up a gofundme page that raised fifty
thousand dollars for medical expenses
wow we had a another good friend and
neighbor who she literally took over the
schedule for us she
every sunday night she'd come over she'd
visit with me
she said here's who's bringing you
dinners on what night
here's the kid's schedule here's who's
going to take them to to dance to music
the play date
and here's who's going to provide child
care while you need to be at the
hospital with your wife
it's just unbelievable
an old college friend she works for a
children's book company now
a book of children's books showed up on
our doorstep
anonymous donor after anonymous donor
just sent us a bunch of money
one night in november i heard a knock on
the door i opened the door
it was the son of
who used to be our neighbors when we
moved in to the neighborhood in 2018
our next door neighbors were an elderly
couple who had dementia and my wife and
my daughters had befriended this this
lady
and did puzzles with her play games with
her and things like that in the last few
months of her life while she struggled
with dementia
so her son showed up on our doorstep and
he said hey we've heard the story and we
just wanted to help make your christmas
a little brighter and gave us a whole
bunch of cash wow from their family to
ours
another small community close to us they
do a giving tree every year and somehow
they caught wind of our story
so they donated that tree to our family
it's basically an artificial tree with
envelopes full of just different cash
and money and things like that man i
mean enough blankets i mean you you're
just smothered with love
it's overwhelmed yep exactly how's your
baby doing
baby is doing really well honestly he
came home and he's developing um appears
to be very normal developing and he's
doing great praise guys
and prognosis on your wife's paralysis
will it be there or you think she'll
work through it
um i think we think it's going to
continue to get a little bit better over
time she'll probably have some level of
deficit forever but
she's making progress every week so
we're really grateful for that
well you just gave a complete diagram of
of how to walk into people's lives and
and save them when they're
reeling uh it's beautiful
absolutely beautiful
wow
man
merry christmas thanks for sharing that
brett
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
do
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we are on a
mission to transform so many lives
that we disrupt this toxic culture
what's all that mean well imagine a
world where it's weird to have a student
loan imagine a world where it's
weird to have a marriage
or career that's not working we want to
show you how to live life right or a
credit card is the cigarette of the
financial industry which it is
now imagine being part of a team that's
making all that reality
happen whether you're writing code or
shipping a book
we're disrupting stuff around here we
create digital products and services if
you want to join us on this crusade we
are on the hunt big time for developers
ux designers seo content marketing
specialists
data engineers the digital space is
exploding around here we got 1058 team
members right now and they are doing
work that actually matters i was talking
to a coder at lunch one of our top dev
guys
uh i sat down a table with him just
having a conversation this week and he
said it's just really nice to
work 40 hours a week because most of the
developer world they work 80
i work they would just run them in the
dirt and um and he said it's also really
nice know when i write a line of code
it's probably helping somebody's life be
changed rather than just
pounding some product out there into the
marketplace and he's right
so find out about all of our available
jobs by checking out ramseysolutions.com
careers we've got a lot of stuff that's
not digital too so
well we'll hire about 350 to 400 more
folks in the year of 22 coming up and so
uh get lined up with us here go to
ramseysolutions.com
careers
open phones at
825-5225 it's our annual giving show
nancy is in washington d.c nancy tell us
your giving story
hi dave thanks for the call um our
giving story is about a scholarship we
set up at my husband's alma mater we are
a marine corps family retire now and we
are baby step millionaires having paid
off our home in 2018. way to go
i know
before our final mortgage payment we
began talking about what our budget
would be like without the house payment
my husband played football at university
before he joined the marine corps and he
said he wanted to donate to a student
football player who was also a military
veteran he contacted the coach but was
told ncaa rules would not allow this
and i said well okay well we should do a
scholarship and he's and he tells me
this
he found this out while we were driving
a u-haul across country and uh
first he thought it was nuts
um but the idea came from one of the
stories in your book retired inspired
and he just couldn't imagine that we are
the kind of people who set up a
scholarship
so we're in this year that sounds like
stuff rich people do
right right you know
yeah really
and so he's my captive audience in this
u-haul and i asked him let's brainstorm
the idea anyway and after a few days he
realized it was possible so we now have
a three thousand dollar a year
scholarship for a student
who has an interest in
federal service after graduation
the applicants write an essay
[Music]
about how their career goals will help
others or what they've learned about
leadership through
work or community engagement
so our curtin awardee is an air force
veteran he's in his second year of the
award and he's a junior in school
and also through my husband's company
they have a charitable match program and
we were able to secure an additional one
thousand dollars for our student
scholarship awardee
and uh he
he was awarded four thousand dollars in
his first award year
and
also
we are at the school visiting promoting
our scholarship and we were speaking
with the veteran student advisor to tell
her about our scholarship
she gave us a tour of a little break
room that the veteran students have that
they can come and you know take a break
and whatnot
they were raising money to renovate that
space and because we were debt-free
we were able to donate and then five
thousand dollars to that campaign
i love it
wow exactly
it's wonderful and we could not have
done it if we had not followed
the financial peace program and we would
not have been out of that and debt free
to to
give back in this small way wow that's
powerful you guys are amazing well done
well done that's good you know we have
found that with uh we've actually now
made it uh kind of a rule with our
ramsey family foundation uh and it's
exactly what you all did that we want to
uh we don't give just to random things
we give to something that is attached to
one of us so like your husband's a
veteran and played ball so you're you
know your giving was attached to him and
his history and the way he did things
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
exactly that way or that thorough that's
a very thorough attachment but just
something that we
one of us and their family has has a has
a burden for a care about
um versus just is it a good thing
because there's always more good things
than there is money
to give to but uh we just try to you
know emotional attachment spiritual
attachment historical attachment
to one of us in some way is
uh you know it's almost a a filter for
the things that we decide to give to in
the ramsey family so good for you i like
that that's very good nancy i like it
and so this is perpetual you're doing
this every year
yes yes um
so
the
um because the students are either it's
just for sophomores juniors or seniors
and they the awardee can um have it
their entire you know three years of uh
the school depending on when they apply
yeah yeah if they're if they're going to
be there three you know for the three
more years then you could just leave it
with them and
help usher them all the way out that's
perfect i like it
good job touchdown congratulations i
like it pete is in spokane washington
hey pete tell me your giving story merry
christmas
merry christmas dave nice to talk to you
you too
so um my family we uh we had a family
business
uh and our much larger competitor bought
us out a couple years ago and and that
set us up you know well for our
retirement and for life
and recently
this year we had a
high school classmate that high school
class of my wife and myself
and she's been having some struggles
financially
and at the same time her uh her mom
passed away
and we were able to
purchase her mom's house from the estate
so that she could live in it
so we gave her the money to purchase the
house from the estate
that's fun how much was that
it was a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars yeah ding ding yeah so a little
a few tears there when she gets the keys
to her mom's house debt free
absolutely
we also gave her 30 000 on top of that
to pay off her car loan
some credit card debt and another
personal loan that she had wow and gave
her a little starter emergency fund well
she's on her way now
yeah we pretty much set her up so she
can have a comfortable rest of her life
we hope all she's got to do is run run
the lane now you got the lane laid out
exactly beautiful beautiful well done so
when you sold the business what'd you
sell it for how much
oh it was uh
it was like i i was a part owner so my
my share was
roughly 11 million dollars i'd say okay
very good yeah i like that a nice
liquidity event yeah very good but yeah
that's the way to put it yeah so you can
you can look up you know when you've got
11 million you can look over and drop
130 and it's like buying a biscuit
exactly well we can't do it every year
but boy when we feel we feel called we
we sure felt called in this case yeah
when god serves it up on a platter you
just gotta go yeah there it is
exactly and that there was no question
in your mind at any point in this
process that this lady was named
a in need but also deserving
we were both completely on board yeah
for sure
fall
i like it
yeah i like talking to evil rich people
[Laughter]
hey man way to go pete i'm proud of you
proud of your success and i'm proud of
your generosity i'm honored to know you
thank you for calling in with that
so one of your relatives tells pete
tells you that all rich people are evil
over the holidays
you'll just have to tell them about pete
okay
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's our annual ramsey giving show we
dedicate entire the entire three hours
of our last live broadcast of the year
to the subject of generosity if you've
been giving or you've been receiving and
you have a great story to inspire and to
lift and encourage others to join the
generosity train
to jump on board
call me the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five
two two five our audience needs to hear
your generosity story we've got 1058
folks here on the ramsey team and
a precursor to joining the ramsey team
is we try to hire good people
not just people who can do a job
we are people of character
because that's who we want to hang
around with because guess what you
become who you hang around with and so
you hang around a bunch of scum you
become scummy you know what i'm saying
hang around good people you become good
people and so consequently we have an
incredible team
of packed full of generous people
margaret close is on our hr team
she's a team engagement specialist i
didn't even know that was your title
she's been with us for four years she
and lee for instance one of the things
they do uh her cohort in crime they do
two days of onboarding for new team
members every two weeks and i'll always
slip in there and spread a little
dissension on the new people and uh
she's in there guiding that and cringing
while i'm doing it so uh it works out
great margaret is a gym and i can't wait
to hear your giving story i'm just here
to get you back dave for all those times
you sat in my onboarding
well there you go not knowing what i was
going to say and now the roles are
reversed i have no idea what you're
going to say
well i am so grateful that we even do
this show because there's so many things
that i want to shout out with our
specific team in my season recently so
uh four years ago i came here as an
assistant and i didn't know what the
future would hold and now i'm in a dream
job i didn't know existed
but two years ago i met a man online and
we quickly fell in love but realized we
live in different states
somebody's gotta move somebody's gotta
uproot their entire world and
make the other person happy to pursue
them and so um
this man moved for me in the middle of
2020 left his home that he sold his
career his church everything to come and
pursue what our future would look like
here and there was a lot of fear with
the job transition and what that future
might hold and so we just took those
steps of faith and after two years
um
i was going on a walk with my leader
who's right over here she and a few
others conspired at the office over a
lunch break
i went on a brainstorming walk with her
bumped into my fiance who was waiting to
walk me down that country lane and
propose oh
it was a setup it was an absolute setup
this team is incredible so you'll see
some photos here and dave i think you
were there right after all the hype so i
like to say i put a engagement and
engagement specialist and so
and it's not on purpose but we are
getting married on the same day that i s
that my work anniversary is i just love
this place so much
that's just a little weird yeah it's a
little weird not on purpose
but all that to say the generosity that
has come i have had to repaint the
picture a couple of times because i'm
debt free and he brings some student
loan and car loans into things and we
want to responsibly move forward
financially and have a plan with that
but it definitely wasn't the disney
princess picture that i had and do you
know how much weddings cost
i've heard the rumor oh my word you get
engaged and it's immediately the sticker
shock on everything i mean
just to rent pipe and drape was our
entire budget
so there goes the pipe and drape um and
we just had to figure out our priorities
very quickly and
there's so much turmoil
just wondering what our
future and our celebration would look
like
and that was for about a month and then
my spiritual mentor here kate stratton
invited me to a father's heart weekend
we both got to go at that weekend we
really just were
kind of we kind of had a reset of what's
important what really matters how do we
want our wedding to represent
the true father god's heart
well we went to dinner that next week
with rich and lynn hodge who led the
retreat they've been with wyoming for 20
years as missionaries
and they said margaret we really
feel drawn to you guys we love you all
as a couple and we want to come
alongside
and bless you with a honeymoon
there you go everything included and so
turnkey turnkey and that was a huge
relief because we're planning a move and
a wedding and our international trip and
it's so much going on and they said we
want to invest in you guys and the start
of your relationship
we have a phone call with them tonight
to confirm the destination so i'll keep
you posted all right
but a couple other things we've got in
our venue for free our
new church has been incredible my
wedding planner is here at ramsey
video and photography have been donated
so that they can use it for marketing
there's a couple friends over here that
i was working with last night to
assemble some floral arrangements and
who are helping to calligraphy and
dave the response has been so
overwhelming especially from the ramsay
team which truly has become like family
so i cannot thank you enough for just
the culture that is here
when
life happens
i feel so good there's good life
happening yeah this is a good life
good good so what's the date january
29th all right coming up fast 38 days
but who's counting but who's counting in
four hours and 22 minutes yeah but all
right look at this that's what good for
you i'm so proud of you well done you're
an incredible team member incredible
lady but that is a great story
and uh
yeah you guys will be in a position
before you know it to reverse those uh
reverse those directions and and be
buying honeymoons the rest of your life
you never know
so um uh that's that's very very cool
somehow god usually gives us an
assignment that's similar to the one
that was with us you know and so good
for you so well done
good and honored to have you on the team
you're you're incredible thanks dave
very very well done merry christmas
merry christmas margaret close from our
team team engagement specialist in hr
works there and uh
welcoming our new folks on board good
stuff good stuff so let's hear what your
giving story is
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five bryce is in idaho
falls idaho merry christmas bryce
hey
hey what's up hello hey
oh
not a whole heck of a lot just uh
sharing my story
so a couple years ago last year just
before covid i uh wife and i got out of
debt and got our emergency fund stored
and i got laid off and so
i
took the opportunity to take a few
months and i was riding my mountain bike
is enjoying life and
came across a corner and broke my wrist
oh
yeah and it costs rough wealth of course
you go to the hospital and the hospital
tells you well if you pay for it today
you can save about 10 grand otherwise
it's going to be 26 000
so we used our emergency fund and every
dime of it and
paid cash so we'd have to pay that extra
10 grand yeah but that left us with
doctor bills of course
and so uh
we had a local lady in the yard in the
town she offered to do a
facebook
auction which raised a couple thousand
dollars
but then we happen to be visiting my
mother-in-law here in idaho because we
were living in wyoming at the time
and my wife
received a phone call out of the blue
from a old family friend that she grew
up with and uh she says i want i've been
praying that i needed to uh help some
people and your name kept coming to my
mind
but i need you to come over in person to
pick it up
and we just
happened to be in town of course
nothing's ever happens dance right so um
and we went over there to her and she
says i want to
help you guys and i don't know why but i
need to give you five thousand dollars
whoa
yeah
um
we uh
we were shocked it was basically almost
the exact amount we needed to pay off
all the doctors
and still have
about a thousand dollars left in our
emergency for a new emergency fund to
start building our big one
powerful it
it was uh probably the most amazing
experience i've had in a long long time
amen
great story bryce thanks for sharing
your generosity story that's powerful
it's always the exact amount too that's
the way it works when god lines it up
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's our annual generosity show here on
the ramsey show we're taking calls from
you
about times that you were on the
receiving or the giving end
of generosity we're trying to inspire
more generosity and sometimes the way we
inspire that is you just get an idea
from one of these things it's something
you might do you're like oh you know i
was just thinking about that and then
that came on the radio so there you go
that came on the podcast so there you go
that came on the youtube so there you go
and then you go home and you go do it
this is perfect that's what we want to
do we want to spread this out because uh
generosity is uh highly attractive and
it's what makes this um make this whole
money thing work nick is with us in
lubbock texas hi nick welcome to the
ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve tell me your giving story
well i have a receiving and a giving
story
the receiving story is
a couple years ago my wife and i were
going through a hard time i had a hard
loss
of a dear friend and we were looking for
a new to us
minivan
and we came across one and the couple
that we met with um it had been well
taken care of it's an 04 model
and
as we were doing the title transfer
you know we were kind of telling our
story we had a little one
and they
they decided to pay for all the
title tax and license transfer over
and then we told them our story about
how we were on your plan saving up for
[Music]
nursing school and you know trying to
pay off student loan debt
and they uh they offered to help us out
um
while we were going through nursing
school wow well nursing school didn't
pan out and so what they've done instead
is we just had another little one back
in june
and they have given us a year's supply
worth of diapers oh my gosh
yeah so that's been a huge yeah it's
been a really huge help and they've just
been a great couple they send our
daughters books and clothes and
just
all because of a minivan wow
so and then our uh our giving story is
um
you know we were this was still before
we found out about nursing school but
we've been saving up for that
and one of uh one of my co-workers uh
came down with covered really bad
um to the point where he was
hospitalized and had to have a blood
transfusion
well he got out and he was released on
oxygen
and he ended up listening to the wrong
people and taking his oxygen off early
and ended up back in the hospital almost
dying and had to have a second blood
transfusion oh my goodness
he is the sole provider for his family
his wife and his four kids
um and had been out of work for almost a
month at this point and i worked for a
local landscaping company so it's you
know we make they take care of us but
it's not you know it's not bukus of
money
well uh i talked with my wife you know a
bunch of the guys got together and we
decided that we were going to help them
out
some of the guys helped in other ways
than what we did but my wife and i
decided that
we were going to help pay his rent oh
good and so i met up with the landlord
and um
his rent wasn't
outrageous and so
we paid his rent all the way through
january 1. all right
all right yes sir and
so we paid for four months of rent
uh to get his family through you know
this this turmoil
and then through the holiday season as
well and so and now he's back at work
and i think things are going better for
him but
it's all been possible because you know
we followed your baby steps well and and
because you kept your heart open in the
process oh my gosh that's wonderful
very nice great job hey that's good you
know paying rent or paying a light bill
through the end of the year or something
like that those are very tangible
things that you can do
and you you are you have a hundred
percent assurance of what the money is
doing
you don't ever have sometimes if you
give somebody cash you don't know where
it's going to end up exactly
right
and yes sir that's not to be uh selfish
or something like that but you need to
be wise in your generosity and what
you're doing there just going straight
to the landlord paying the rent that was
very wise and and unbelievably generous
so that that's a good model to follow i
like that a lot
very good quote very good job man way to
go nick feels good doesn't it
yes sir absolutely it was it was a great
my wife and i have always been generous
but we've never had the extra income or
the extra money to do that
and so this is a huge game changer you
know we're we're out of debt now so it
makes all things possible oh that
changes every i mean you got some money
now broke people can't help people that
are hurting you know i mean it's like
you know it's a pretty basic math thing
but you know we got this bunch running
around out there in america today just
running down everybody that's successful
and anybody who's built wealth must be a
must be a grifter
must be a horrible person if they're
successful and you know that's just crap
you know you people
y'all ought to be ashamed of yourselves
and telling that because if you listen
to this show today you find out people
good people get money good things happen
and it does happen and by the way that's
usually who ends up getting money
so good stuff well done sir touchdown
our annual giving show amy is with us in
grand rapids michigan amy tell me your
giving story
hi dave thank you so much for having me
on it's such a pleasure to talk to you
my husband and i are huge fans
we would not have met if not for you and
we would not have been able to make the
domain donation that we did if not for
your principles
so my husband and i right after we got
married in june we made a five thousand
dollar donation to a
charity a non-profit that's very close
to our hearts
it's called building for bridget and
it was it is
a nonprofit founded by my sister and
brother-in-law my brother-in-law is from
africa and they are building a school in
his in his home village
actually
yes and it's going to serve
125 kids
when it opens in january of 2023 but
my husband and i actually met in a dave
ramsey facebook group right before the
pandemic because we are both huge
followers of yours my husband is from
michigan i lived in wisconsin at the
time
and we both knew that we wanted somebody
who was financially savvy and
what better way to meet that person than
in a dave ramsey facebook group
so so
we um
we
when we got married we well before we
got married um we had come up with a
very detailed plan
and we said one of our goals is to be
outrageously generous like you talk
about and so we allocated
this five thousand dollars that we were
going to donate
as a way to celebrate our wedding as
soon as as soon as we came back from our
our honeymoon
and so
that's that's what we did we um we got
married in june we ended up taking a
family vacation rather than a honeymoon
on our honeymoon right now actually
and and um so as soon as we came back in
june right after our wedding we made the
donation
and
it's been it's helped help fund the
school and we hope that we're going to
be able to
continue to be charitable
through the rest of our married life and
my my husband actually hit everyday
millionaire status right before our
wedding wow
yes and i was so proud of him um he's 40
he was 44 year old engineer at the time
and then when we got married and
combined finances like what you talked
about
that put us solidly
in the millionaire status so now
we have
we have a line item in our budget for
giving and we're hoping to continue this
we want to continue being generous with
the rest of our married life and we both
cannot thank you enough well i'm proud
of you way to go
you're amazing i mean five thousand
dollars it feels like a lot of money and
it is a lot of money but here's what's
strange the more you do it the less
it'll feel
yes and we are very much looking forward
to that so thank you thank you so much
dave well thank you merry christmas to
you that's a great story that's awesome
but the way to start your married life
is in generosity so uh would you guess
that people who have a pattern
of giving money
being generous
have a higher probability of success in
their marriage
well duh they're not selfish
number one cause of problems in marriage
selfishness
including my 40-year one
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host this is
the ramsey show today
all three hours we are dedicating to the
subject of generosity there are five
things you must do with money if you
want to succeed
with money over the long haul one of
them is you have to develop the muscle
of generosity
and like any other muscle it must be
worked out in order to be developed you
must practice
generosity and generosity is sometimes
and oftentimes more than it's a
character quality
not just an action of giving money
you can actually have people who give
money who are not generous believe it or
not that's possible
but we want to talk about giving money
and we want to talk about the giving
heart and we want to talk with you and
hear your story of a time that giving
intersected your life and changed your
life
a time that you were on the giving end
or the receiving end and it left a mark
it changed the people involved
and uh thereby you give other people
that are listening and inspiration to be
givers
and uh ideas on how they might give the
things they might do the thing you might
want to change out there
and i'm not talking about you left the
20 tip whoopi okay that's wonderful i'm
glad you did that do that all the time
make sure you take care of people that's
not the question i'm talking about
something where you go wow
that's pretty cool
yeah the show is all about generosity
it's our annual ramsay show
giving
edition
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
andrea or andrea is with us in sarasota
florida hey andrea what's up
hi dave um thank you for having me on
the show today and i just wanted to also
say thank you for the positive impact
you've had on my life since i became a
listener about a decade ago wow well
thank you merry christmas tell us your
giving story
okay so
back in 2009 i earned my master's in
music performance at a conservatory in
the grano switzerland
after graduating i was completely broke
and had no job prospects i came and
boomeranged as you said
back home to florida and at that time
our economy was complete trash
orchestras around the country were
closing
i also didn't really know if that's what
i wanted to do anyway
so i applied to around 200 different
places and finally got a job as a sales
associate at macy's for 7.25 an hour
and then six months later i started
working as a substitute teacher
um after a very tough year back
stateside i became the band director at
my alma mater southeast high school in
bradenton florida
this is now my 12th year there we're
title 1 school and i work many many long
hours
but my admin and colleagues are super
supportive my students are amazing and
talented
hilarious there's never a dull moment
around here so it's truly my dream job
cool um
all that being said during my first
couple years of teaching i was
completely overwhelmed with working so
much my personal life was in shambles
my dad was suffocating me and i love my
job so like i can't even imagine what it
would be like to not love your job but i
felt um trapped even still and i had so
much anxiety and i would just like sit
in my car at my desk and just breaking
down crying
um
i sort of knew who you were at the time
but my twin sister kelly really is the
one who got me on board um and so i
started listening to your show on
podcast later on i read the books went
through a few
and started following your other ramsey
personalities so with some encouragement
and help along the way and perseverance
and most importantly a plan i got myself
out of 64 000 worth of debt um my debt
consisted of student loans a car note
credit card debt furniture debt and uh
financed schnoodle anya who i
affectionately call my best worst
decision
there's more to answer to all that but
basically since march 2015 right before
i turned 30 i've been debt free thanks
to you thank you way to go proud of you
so
then jump to december 27 2019
our grandfather grandpaville passed away
um and he left my sister
and i
472 thousand dollars each goodness
yeah
we had absolutely no idea that that was
going to happen and that kick started
our 2020
um a year like many for many um with
some really high highs and some very low
lows um
but with that money i was able to buy
the house i live in from my mom
my sister kelly and her husband vance
paid off their house
and um my sister i
both gave thirty thousand dollars to our
cousins um
we also invested a lot and upgrade our
cars
my sister gives to many organizations
including woodstock city church nazarene
fund and her orchestra
alpharetta symphony orchestra
i also give to the nazarene fund and my
school
particularly our band program um
and over the years i've probably donated
around 60 000
um
donated instruments and equipment paid
for banned staff paid for students to
attend honor bands just fun things and
necessary things all alike
um
and then
this past year i was also able to foster
one of my students for almost a year
i gave her my old car
wow
just keeps going and going it does um
and like i'm a fairly private person and
you know for someone who majored in
performance uh i prefer to be behind the
scenes but i wanted to encourage others
to share their stories because it's
inspiring and and also just like about
becoming debt-free like you always say
like teachers are like the number three
um
uh job to like uh
be millionaires so even teachers can do
it even musicians can do it i got myself
filed of debt and on a plan and i was
giving generously
with time and resources before i was
gifted the money um
and i know like
the other day i heard you say on the
radio like um
you're not going to give money or leave
money to people you don't know or people
you barely know um and that just
reminded me of like my mom always
encouraging us to
communicate with our family and and
write cards and just like the little
things that add up and i truly believe
like that's why
i was blessed with this my sister and i
um because we learned how to manage
money in god's way by saving some
spending some giving some and also by
giving thanks man amen so thank you
sounds like your grandpa was a special
dude
yes very much and they called him
hollywood yeah i like him a very big
personality i like it i like him he well
and he left his granddaughters a million
bucks that's pretty strong exactly and i
mean not just us i mean he left you know
my my mom and my aunt my oh you know a
bunch of money too so yeah he definitely
you know
created a legacy with all that now i'm
on my way to become a baby steps
millionaire yeah and no question uh
grandpa bill is uh smiling from heaven
on you well done
well done wow a lot going on there but
here's the thing giving is not as simple
as a one-time thing it starts sometimes
with a one-time thing but you heard her
story there's giving all over it
she was ever everywhere you there
everything she touched there's tentacles
everywhere and then receiving also hello
that's how it all works beautifully done
well done thank you for sharing darlin
merry christmas to you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
well we all know the story of the
tortoise and the hare and we know that
the tortoise wins because he was slow
and steady and slow instead he always
wins the race
but what we don't do oftentimes in that
story is back up and say
well here's
what happened to the hare
he couldn't keep his eye on the ball he
took a nap
he didn't play through
and if you've been running around all
over the place chasing your tail like
the hair maybe this is your wake-up call
we want 2022 to be your best
wealth building year yet
for just a few more days we've got all
kinds of life-changing books and tools
in our famous ten dollar sale these ten
dollar books could be a huge return on
investment for you and they also make
great gifts
getting books like the number one best
seller the total money makeover
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
weeks on the bestseller list dr john
deloney's quick read redefining anxiety
all 10 bucks rachel cruz's newest new
york times best seller know yourself
know your money
10 bucks
there's something for everyone
make 2022 your best wealth building year
yet
shop at the 10 sale before it ends
at ramsey ramseysolutions.com
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code the magic word
ramsay to get the best
possible deal
today's question comes from justin in
delaware my niece will celebrate her
first birthday soon and i'd like to give
her a gift that my brother and his
girlfriend can't cash out or keep for
themselves although i've not met my
niece yet i love her dearly what avenues
can i take to set her up for a
successful financial future having the
ability to contribute to the gift on
future birthdays and holidays will be a
plus are there any ideas or advice you
would recommend sure
you can open a 529 or just a mutual fund
in the child's name and you can set
yourself up as the custodian
you merely need the child social
security number and you would want to
notify the parents of course that you're
doing this and you can notify them how
much you're putting in there and those
kinds of things you're the custodian you
will manage the good money on behalf of
the child until the child reaches
21.
at 21 it is their money
and you no longer have any control over
it
and that's how a custodial account works
and by the way that's how any kind of
bank account or investment is done on
behalf of a child
their children are unless you're 21
you're not are 18
in no state in the union are you able to
contract or do con enter into a legal
binding contract so you can't open a
bank account
with just the kid name
the kid's name got the parent's name on
it or somebody else is a custodian you
can't open a mutual fund just a kid's
name uh unless someone else is the
custodian
for on behalf of the kid now the kid can
have to be the owner of the account but
they they can't you just can't you know
like i can just have one just in my name
but you can't do that if you're 14.
it has to have a an adult's name on the
account as well and there they are the
managing
party
of the account called the custodian
and so when you open a mutual fund a
kid's name it's taxed at the kids rate
which is nothing unless there's a bunch
of money in there and it starts actually
making so much money in a given year
that it creates a taxable event for the
child
that be that you'd have a lot of money
in there at that point
and the things making a really good rate
of return as well
so
uh
probably what i would do in this case
is open a 529 which is for use for
education it'll grow tax-free you can
set yourself up as the custodian
but again you need to have a
conversation with the parents that this
is your intent hey i'm going to open
this account so i can give to it
regularly i'm going to put 5 000 in
there the first year
and i'm going to add to it as i go along
i'll be the custodian i'll send you guys
the statements let you know what's going
on just as a courtesy uh and you know
and you can communicate we'll all
communicate with the child as the child
grows that they've got their college or
their future or whatever it is taken
care of and that's a beautiful beautiful
way to do that and that's a nice nice
thing that you're talking about doing
for a niece or for a nephew
very cool
and the beautiful thing is it sounds
like the parents are probably immature
or out of control or something and that
way they don't go spend it on some silly
thing thing or some evil thing or
something like that and the money
actually stays with the child
and so um because you're in control of
it and uh and that that's a that's what
i would do in this case uh because the
way you describe this you you and i read
between the lines that you don't trust
the parents for whatever reason
immaturity or misbehavior or whatever
so hey man that's very cool today is the
giving show the annual giving show on
the ramsey show we do this every year
three hours of stories from you
about giving
and about receiving
the importance of generosity
so jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money it is a free call let's
hear it let's hear your giving story
triple eight eight two five
five two two five mike is with us in
amarillo texas hey mike welcome to the
ramsey show tell me your giving story
hi dave merry christmas merry christmas
hey uh we've been my wife and i we've
been long-time listeners ever since town
hall for hope back in 2009. wow and uh
we've um learned a lot about money since
then and i just wanted to be able we've
uh gotten to have some fun with
generosity and i wanted to share some
fun we got to have because of the ramsey
show
so
uh so last january we i was listening to
the ramsey show um i heard a caller call
in from my hometown so my interest was a
little bit peaked i was like all right
what's she calling about um
she said she was a single mom she'd been
working the baby steps
and she was trying to figure out at what
point to start her dream of going to
dental hygienist school
she didn't know how to afford it
but she was she was considering leaving
a good administrative assistant job to
wait tables at night
but she was really worried about
being able to follow through
with schooling just with work-life
balance and her her daughter
so you and ewan hogan kind of talked to
her and gave her some
some real encouragement told her she
could do it um
but in the call she gave enough info
about her job
and we're a smallish town so i did some
stalking
and i found her workplace on google
so then i had my wife listen to the call
i didn't tell her why
she thought it was it was a really
amazing story i'm just hearing that uh
the struggle the girl had but um just
really uh wanted to be able to encourage
her um and so i said what do you think
if we gave her a gift and she was like
how would we find her i said well i
already did the stalking
so
she said always good to let your wife in
on the fact that you're stalking someone
yeah yeah i let her know i didn't hide i
didn't hide that i did some google and
linkedin work but um
so we talked about it and she said we
really that'd be a great encouragement
for that'd be a lot of fun
so we went uh we got um 500 cash from
the the bank and we put in an envelope
we wrote some scripture
out for her we prayed over it and her
and her daughter
and we
uh
and and we encouraged her in the car
just to follow her dreams go do what she
wants to do
and just put in the work so we went to
the office where she was an assistant uh
it was still covid time so the office
was closed
but we knocked on the door
a girl came we said hey is this person
here she said that's me and we had no
idea so uh
we said okay we gave her the card we
said be blessed and we turned and walked
to the elevator and went down and
i have no idea what she thought like she
probably was like what just happened um
i know it was a lot of fun we were giddy
on the way back to the car i'm just
thinking it was fun and what surprise
she had when she opened that uh that day
so
um
good for you
you put some effort into this i mean you
this is this is well thought out well
executed
good job man i like that
hey proud of you proud of you that's
what it's all about that's what this
show is about today it's all about
generosity
merry christmas america this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
it's our annual giving show on the
ramsay show all about generosity this
hour
and for the last two hours as well open
phones if you want to tell us your
giving or your receiving story we'd love
to hear it
make it something good so that other
people are inspired to do just that we
got 1058 people on the ramsey team and i
got to tell you we hire good people only
unless you completely fool us in the
interview
we are great folks and uh
part of being a great folk is being
incredibly generous so we always invite
our team to also participate
in this giving hour kate stratton's been
with us three and a half years uh she
works in identity and access
administration over the i.t team and got
a great giving story hey kate merry
christmas thank you merry christmas to
you too dave so good to have you so tell
me all about your giving story all right
well my story of giving is very near and
dear to my heart
hundreds of people have given their time
talents and treasures to my brother bob
and his wife barb
last january this year january
bob was in a grocery store at the
grocery store putting his groceries into
the back of his car
and
as he was doing that a
gentleman
that was under the influence
drove and hit bob
and
emts got there so fast they saved his
life in the ambulance on the way wow
they um there were the emergency doctors
that did exactly what they needed to do
the first week we were on pins and
needles whether bob would even make it
or not wow bob made it
he um lost both legs above the knee oh
my goodness yeah
um just so many people it was a brutal
accident this was a brutal accident life
changed like that wow yeah yeah
and so but bob is just incredible dave
he's got an incredible attitude he has
been moving forward on every part of
this and just been positive and said you
know what hey at least it's not my um
internal organs at least my back's not
broken this could be worse it's kind of
his attitude he's amazing and i think
it's be that because of that is why he
is healing so well
so
physical therapists nurses all of them
love them because when they come into
the room bob would be like how you doing
great to see you thank you so much i
mean they they he was encouraging them
even more than they were encouraging him
which is beautiful wow just that's who
he is so the first week that this
happened a good friend of ours from high
school said kate we got to do something
i want to start a gofundme for bob sure
because you know the expenses are going
to be crazy oh yeah i mean for lifelong
expenses
and um so
over 300 people dave friends
acquaintances
um family gave to bob even people here
at ramsey that don't even know him gave
to this gofundme and they raised over
ninety thousand dollars wow
yeah to coming together so the story's
not done yet so um
going on what they do when this happens
they want as soon as those stumps get
healed they want to get them into legs
as soon as possible
and so
they um the physical therapists and all
the wound therapy and all those people
they um got him into his legs so bob has
been walking and it starts really small
and then they add on the lengths and
things
so he um is walking with these legs
and about two and a half weeks ago he's
walking by the way with a k with a um
walker and has to hold on really hard
and it's a workout he sweats just you
know a couple lengths
well he started for the first time
losing hope because he realized with
these legs
that he can't even go up a ramp or go
over a step
and for the first time he just was like
i'm kind of getting into a dark place
why do i even even bother
so the physical therapist saw it and
they said bob come in and try these
upgraded legs just try them
and dave he was on you know they have
parallel bars where they're practicing
and when on the old legs he was holding
on really tight on these new upgraded
legs bob could walk first time just
barely holding on oh my gosh game
changer game changer wow problem is
insurance didn't cover it
and they are very expensive so they just
kind of bob and his wife barb just kind
of said okay i guess we just have to
wait we'll just have to wait till we can
do this what is very expensive um close
to a hundred thousand dollars wow the
80s yeah okay yeah
and so
um
a few days later they find out that
someone
wants to an anonymous giver wants to buy
bob the lakes
and they said hey if if possible if they
can make it to where it's a
tax-deductible
um thing that'd be great if not don't
worry about it we want you to walk
and so
bob being who bob is didn't just say
okay just give them to me bob went and
researched and he found a foundation
down in florida called 50 lakes
50 legs was started by a gentleman who
was an amputee about 10 years ago and he
came up with this idea and he said i
want to try and raise enough money to
get 50 legs in 50 days
10 years later they have helped people
amputees over 560 get into legs wow yeah
so bob applied and said hey maybe they
can help us out
so
that day
after he applied that afternoon they
called him and said we can help you
and bob not only can we help you
but we're gonna
get
to pay for all your travel expenses for
you and your wife
to come down to florida to
pay for hotel to come in with physical
therapy for two weeks
and also we're going to cut the price of
these
um in more than half oh
so
in january um bob is going to be
going down to florida
one year after the accident and he's
going to be in a couple weeks walking
out of there with a
by cane generous giving of so many
people in this story it takes a
community doesn't it i mean it's just as
amazing that's powerful incredibly
excited for him wow yeah and i think it
it's you reap what you sow he's bob
never said in the whole process why me
until
people would start giving him things and
he'd say you know like like they'll go
fund me why me say bob because you love
people so well they want to love you
back
and it's just another example wow that's
powerful yeah it was really good wow
that's good that's good it's amazing how
something that uh like prosthetic
prosthetic legs how do you say i can't
say it
um that you know nothing about when it
gets close to you all of a sudden you
get the whole vernacular and you start
talking about legs yes like what who
talks about legs
but because it's a situation that's
close to you you just develop the
language and you get get comfortable
talking about awkward things really fast
very very neat very neat powerful it's
fine very powerful i love it that's
that's a good use of money he's a good
man yeah so life's changed amen
wonderful amen thank you kate thank you
merry christmas to you as well well done
well done well done
wow
i got to tell you there's uh
the guy that started that ministry or
that that charity you know uh 50 leagues
in 50 days right it came from his loss
right so it's not unusual at all
that the trauma
the problem
the thing that was happening to you when
someone stepped in with generosity
becomes the thing that
um
that you are generous with
you're always going to be sensitive if
you're a single mom you have trouble
paying your bills you're always going to
be sensitive to and have a tendency
towards giving to single moms who
couldn't pay their bills
uh whatever your situation
is whatever was going on you know you at
that time that can turn and become your
thing
become your assignment so to speak
and i don't have to be a full-time
assignment it's just that you have a
you have an eye for it because you've
been there
you understand how it feels
and uh it changes the direction of
everything involved
so very well done so very well done i
love that story this is the annual
giving show where we talk about
generosity
the entire show to inspire you not only
at christmas
to be generous
but just generosity in general boys and
girls it's a financial principle to
develop that in your character
this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today isaiah 9 6 for unto
us a child is born
to us a son is
given
and the government shall be upon his
shoulder
and his name shall be called wonderful
counselor mighty god
everlasting father
prince of peace
bob hope said when we recall christmas
past we usually find that the simplest
things
not the great occasions
give off the greatest glow
of happiness
well that's definitely true
this show today is all about giving and
all about generosity
and as those of us that are christians
we understand that god gave
his only
begotten son that we might have
everlasting life and that's what the
season is about
the arrival of the messiah
and uh it's not a joke and it's not a
it's not mythology
it is the day and the person
that changed the course of history
more than any other
single arrival
so when we talk about giving when god
gave
his only
begotten son
that you might
have everlasting life
oh there's an important giving lesson
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five as we ask you
about your giving and your receiving
stories
as we are
inspiring people across america
to be more generous nash is with us nash
is in san diego hi nash merry christmas
hey dave merry christmas to you too mary
tell me your giving story
yeah so actually i was on the receiving
end um long story short i had 75 000
worth of uh student loan debt and um
ended up starting on the baby steps
about 20 months ago wow
and as i was kind of working two jobs
i'm a teacher and i stoke i stock
shelves at a grocery store here and
i still go to church regularly and still
was giving tithe but i was talking to
some people
and they're asking hey do you want to go
out or do you want to do certain things
i was like no i can't i have my other
job i'm trying to pay off my student
loans you know and i just really got
behind your principles and there's this
couple who overheard my story and my
situation
and one day they pulled me aside and
they said
hey we
stumbled not stumbled but we were given
20 grand because i guess they were
the trustees of someone else's trust
and i guess under that will they were
supposed to give money to charity and
they felt that my situation and my story
was was charity enough and they're like
we'd really want to help you out and
give you 20 grand
to go towards your student loans and
when
i still get chills just thinking about
it and my job dropped and i was like no
you don't have to do that you don't have
to do it like i'm learning like this is
the transformation that i'm learning to
be you know a good steward of god's
money they're like no like we really
want to bless you like we can't do
anything with it we want to help you out
and so a couple months went by i guess
for all the paperwork and all that stuff
to to to transpire i get a text saying
um
hey nash
we put in 20 grand to your student loans
take care and i went and checked my
account and it was there and i was just
like oh my gosh this just jump started
me into baby step three and to this day
i i just i can't believe that that
happened amazing wow
and so that was that was really close to
your balance your outstanding balance
yeah so i had 26 000 left and and i kept
playing with the numbers but yeah that
20 grand wiped it out and then i had six
grand left and then within two months i
was able to be completely debt free and
it just the weight lifted off my
shoulders of being
debt-free but also having that gift
meant so much to me because it was just
kind of like god saying you know nash i
see what you're doing
keep doing what you're doing i'm gonna
bless you i'm gonna take care of you and
that was just you know his hand over me
yeah when you're faithful in the little
things you'll be given more to manage
yes and it's kind of like as you said
like that was very much a miracle for me
because
i knew these people but they didn't
really know me you know and and for them
to just kind of take a leap of faith and
believe in me enough to gift me that i
was i'm just incredibly grateful for it
wow
wow way to go that's cool
very cool so what's your degree in
uh so i got my degree in kinesiology i'm
a middle school pe teacher yeah
yeah well you'll be in a position to do
this for somebody someday
oh yes i i can't wait to even now i'm
starting to look forward and i see
someone you know when i i'm stalking
shelves i see someone i'm like man i
can't wait to get out of baby step free
so then i can give someone just you know
50 for groceries you know and just make
an impact because you know we we all
need someone to kind of help reassure us
that you know we're still loved we're
we're not damaged you know god still
loves us amen beautiful well done sir
well done well merry christmas and thank
you for sharing that incredible giving
story rebecca in wichita kansas merry
christmas
hi
rebecca
christmas how are you better than i
deserve tell me your giving story
great okay yes i am on the receiving end
and excuse me i'm kind of nervous about
this um
but um long story short short i am i
worked with and
met an elderly gentleman about 10 years
ago and we worked uh weekly together
um and we he was um
on his appearance when you looked at him
he wore very
like shabby clothes he drove an old beat
up truck i'm pretty sure he lived in
like a house with
no central heat and air and maybe i
think he might have had running water
i'm i think he lived off a well actually
so he lived very very frugally and
there'd always been a rumor that he was
um wealthy he was a bachelor never had
any kids
but always you could tell was always
very giving to people when he would meet
them and he would always everyone so i
would slip me a little cash you know
like for christmas or for my birthday
um always made me feel like he was
thinking about me and
um he passed away um a couple months ago
and um at his funeral
um a few of us were given business cards
to a um a financial service
so um i call the number on the card
and
um
like i said long story short um
but in 2016
he had gone and deposited money
into mutual funds for
several different people um
close people family friends
and these mutual funds um since 2016
have tripled and
um one of them is in my name um oh my so
yeah i am i was
when i talked to the financial lady and
she told me what it was worth
i
i let out a few explicit explicatives
that i wasn't even sure
she was um
i wouldn't would have been very
impressed with but she laughed and said
that she had got the same
she had the same reaction from several
people um
because i was
in my mind i was expecting like a couple
hundred dollars i didn't know what this
was how much was it
well right now they are worth in the
range of about twelve thousand dollars
they've tripled in value
so this old man
this old man and be in the middle of
nowhere kansas that has lived on nothing
his whole life
knows enough about uh finances and funds
and stocks that he did this for people
and i'm not the only one there's no
telling how much people
exactly how much is in some of those
accounts oh my goodness i know and what
he left to his nieces and nephews and
it's just unbelievable what he has done
to leave
his legacy his his name his good
fortune uh
you know a fabulous story rebecca well
done
touchdown i love it merry christmas to
you that's great that's how it's done
all right if you're listening
you have an assignment
no you don't have to open a mutual fund
give somebody ten thousand dollars
your assignment is
to decide
as of this moment
define yourself one of your character
qualities starting right now is you are
a generous person
it's a decision
it doesn't require you give money a
generous person smiles
they hold the door for somebody when
they got groceries
they serve
they're compassionate
they're highly attractive
oh and they give money
and that's you starting now ready set go
that puts us our the ramsay show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace
christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you